foreign
Emma is in San Bernardino Emma welcome
to the Ramsay show
thanks for having me on sure what's your
question
um so my husband is a real estate agent
and he's been with a company for about
three years now
but his boss
um is very inappropriate he's had about
three lawsuits against him for sexual
harassment
he only hires employees who are under
the age of 25 and blonde and skinny
uh is his boss Leonardo DiCaprio
this is wild
yeah and he makes really inappropriate
comments about women and he recently had
an affair with an employee and the
employee got mad at him for whatever
reason and sent out a huge email to tons
of different lenders and other agents
and just basically saying don't hire
these people don't work with them
and I don't really want my husband to be
with this company anymore because of his
boss and how does your husband feel
what's your husband say about all this
um he kind of I mean we haven't really
talked too much I think right now
because my husband's making good money I
don't know if he will really be open to
that but I'm I'm worried he's
something major is going to happen soon
oh my gosh it feels like like you want
to stay in the band on the Titanic
because of the money but we can see it
sinking
yeah that's that's the perfect way to
put it so I think he needs to see the
writing on the wall going this guy's got
multiple lawsuits again some people are
trying to actively take him down the
money may be good now but number one at
what cost
of your soul and sticking around with a
guy of this level of integrity and then
number two going this money may not be
around a year from now as word gets
around in the real estate world
yes he on like a certain is he on a
certain commission system because if
it's like with a company or brokerage
can he just change
brokerages yeah I mean he's had other uh
agencies reach out to him because he is
a really good yeah
and that's usually most of the time
that's where you're gonna find that you
make the money as a real estate agent is
you not necessarily the company now
granted there are some more companies
that will put marketing dollars behind
you and all of that but uh but he's the
secret sauce your husband so regardless
of where he got where he goes he'll be
able to perform and yeah continue to
make great money so my big thing Emma is
I would talk I mean I would be talking
to him about it
and uh just make your feelings clear I'm
not comfortable with you working around
because of his Integrity like the guy is
a creep and it's like if he's a creep
with other people like I'm like oh I
don't know if you just don't want to be
around that and is he doing weird
business like usually when you have a
lack of Integrity in one area of your
life sometimes it spills into other
areas so I would even I would just be
worried from this guy's not even trying
to hide it from like a cultural
standpoint it's really toxic but then
also who knows what he's doing behind
the scenes with yeah this is
like to keep the Leo and Titanic
references going
yeah yeah I mean they've had their place
vandalized because he slept with a
married woman who was an employee and
her husband found out so like three guys
he hired and came and just broke window
so yeah so so we yeah so the boss is one
thing right but it's you and your
husband that need to make this decision
and so that's what I want to focus on
and so the fact that you haven't brought
it up to him yet or that it hasn't been
a conversation
um yeah I mean I I that that's more of a
like a okay here's what's in my control
is hey I can actually whatever the boss
decides to do with his life that's his
issue but my issue here is that my
husband is part of a company that is
obviously just a complete they're not
jumping on the Lifeboat at all anytime
soon is what it sounds keeping the
references going you're welcome so Emma
I would put your life vest on put the
life vest on and let's find him another
job he's a fantastic real estate agent
and that is the common denominator here
not this magical agency that's good
about to go under and talk to your
husband about it and the fact that you
haven't yet I'm like hmm I mean I don't
know that's yeah that's interesting if
it bothered me enough to call a national
radio show it's going to bother me
enough to have a conversation with my
spouse yeah so have that conversation
Emma for sure